I'm Eti,
I'm Bori,
I'm George Glover,
I did the butterfly in the movie,
the plantain,
I did the caterpillar,
the cow's mouth,
bottom half of the flower,
I did the top petals,
grass,
cow eyes, chrysalis,
ears of the cow,
what else? Is that it...?
The stamen! Yeah.
So we've been making this
film for three days now,
from morning to the evening - in
the basement - in the basement,
having our hands painted.
Doing puppetry, particularly with hands,
I find it quite different from
the other forms of puppetry,
because you're literally
embodying something.
Puppets aren't really thought
of as being scientific,
even though there are people
who approach it quite scientifically and
study patterns of movement and things like that.
But I think it's often
thought of as children's.
When Nature first contacted us,
I think I felt surprised and then
immediately kind of excited.
I really like it when science and
the arts combine,
because at school I felt like you
either had to choose to go down the
scientific path or the artistic path. So
when you get options to get a little bit
more involved with science through
the arts it's really satisfying and
hopefully vice versa for people from
Nature who are collaborating with us.